hi this is presh talker let's discuss
ultimate tic-tac-toe and how the first
player always has a winning strategy
ultimate tic-tac-toe is a game i
described in a previous video you should
watch that video first to understand the
rules
in this video we're going to describe
the winning strategy so x first plays in
the center of the center square
this will force o to play somewhere in
one of the center squares
now wherever o plays
x should respond by taking the center of
that
square so o plays the middle right
x should respond by playing the center
this will force o to be in the center
again
and wherever o
picks x will again respond by picking
the center
what x is doing here is giving up
the center square of the large 3x3 grid
but in return capturing the center
squares of most of the smaller 3x3 grids
for o's last move you do not want to
play the center what you want to do is
mimic the same strategy
and force o to play in the same square
wherever o had sent you
so in this case o should be limited to
play in the middle left
now obey
play the center square in this
in which case you should play the
opposite square
so you were playing the middle left you
should play on the middle right now
so you can again
force o to be back to the middle left
so you continue capturing not only have
you captured the center of most square
of most of these small three by three
grids you are now capturing the middle
left
at some point you may not be able to
send o back to the middle left
so then you repeat the strategy a third
time
you've completed a
three in a row
and now you have the middle right at
this point o is trapped wherever
you wherever oh has to play you can
continue to win any of these squares
and get three in a row
so one by one o is going to send you to
squares you can always complete a three
in a row and force o back to the middle
right
and eventually o will have to capitulate
you will get a three in a row
in each of these squares you'll win
these big squares and therefore you will
win the entire game
so if you play
this strategy you can always win please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker
and you can get my books at amazon